vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique à la une ce soir comment
ramener la sécurité au Burkina Faso
c'est l'objectif prioritaire que c'est
fixé le nouveau gouvernement de
transition burkinabé nous entendrons le
nouveau Premier ministre
l'éclatement du principal partie
d'opposition au Tchad les
transformateurs se déchirent à la suite
de la manifestation meurtrière du jeudi
20 octobre qu'ils avaient largement
soutenus Mustapha Masri vice-président a
annoncé ce matin sa démission du parti
nous irons sur place dans ce journal
et nous vous emmènerons en Côte d'Ivoire
à la rencontre de massong JC une
célébrité locale dans son quartier à
Abidjan ou depuis 10 ans cette mère de
famille s'occupe des enfants des rues
surnommés péjorativement les microbes
comment en finir avec la violence qui
gangrène le Burkina Faso depuis
plusieurs années c'est l'objectif
prioritaire défini par le gouvernement
mené par le Premier ministre Apolline
qu'elle aime de tombera déclare avoir
formé un gouvernement de combat
écoutez-le à l'issue du premier Conseil
des ministres présidé par Ibrahim Traoré
arrivée au pouvoir par un putsch le 30
septembre on écoute
c'est un gouvernement de combat qui a
été formé
voilà c'est pas un gouvernement de dîner
de gala le premier objectif
le principal et le prioritaire c'est la
sécurisation du territoire chaque
Burkinabè qui se dit patriote peut y
contribuer à sa façon le deuxième
objectif sera de faire en sorte à
améliorer la qualité de vie des
Burkinabè
pouvoir d'achat
sa liberté insalubrité hygiène fait en
sorte que le Burkinabè puisse vivre de
façon agréable et enfin le troisième
objectif sera
d'améliorer le système de gouvernance
qu'est-ce qui fait que chaque fois il y
a l'instabilité politique
les transformateurs se déchirent et ce à
la suite de la manifestation meurtrière
du 20 octobre dernier dont le parti
était pourtant à l'initiative Mustapha
Masri vice-président a annoncé ce matin
sa démission du parti les précisions de
notre correspondant à Yamina Mamadou
tonnerre dans les rangs du parti les
transformateurs cette démission
intervient 6 jours après la
manifestation violemment réprimée qui a
fait 50 morts et plus de 300 blessés
selon le gouvernement et 81 morts et
plus de 1000 blessés prisonniers selon
l'opposition et la société civile
monsieur Masri dit avoir annoncé à son
président succès Matra sa démission
qu'il justifie par la nouvelle voie
empruntée par le transformateur qui
selon lui n'est plus en face avec ses
valeurs notre lutte a été dévoyée et de
tourner de ses valeurs fondamentales
la conquête du pouvoir
ipso facto absolu au détriment de nos
valeurs a pris le dessus
le leadership qui devait guider nos
actions à laisser la place à la
singularité
en conséquence
autant l'engagement est un soir est un
choix personnel
autant le choix de partir et personnel
toujours guidé par ces valeurs
au lieu de ces valeurs de paix d'unité
de la démocratie et de la lutte
pacifique nous prenons la décision
de nous dissocier et rejetons cette
nouvelle voie prise à laquelle nous ne
nous reconnaissons pas
le bureau exécutif du parti de
transformateur que nous avons réussi à
joindre ces réserves de tout commentaire
pour l'instant
le Premier ministre guinéen entamé ce
mercredi une tournée dans les différents
sièges des partis politiques à Conakry
Bernard goumour rencontre a rencontré
les acteurs politiques de la société
civile pour discuter de la mise en place
d'un cadre dialogue bien inclusif pour
une sortie de crise depuis la prise de
pouvoir par la gente le dialogue entre
les principaux acteurs politiques et les
militaires est au point mort dans le
pays on écoute le Premier ministre
à tourner actuel se situe dans le cadre
de
l'activité préparatoire pour l'ouverture
de ce cadre de dialogue tout cela c'est
pour la stabilité de notre pays vous que
ça soit les partis politiques que ça
soit les autres vivent de la société que
ce soit nous facilitatrices que ça soit
tous les Guinéens
aspire à un climat de paix donc c'est de
ça qu'il s'agit il faut qu'on se
retrouve qu'on se parle
on peut recueilli par Malik Diakité
ce mercredi marque la reprise à Kinshasa
du procès sur le meurtre de
l'ambassadeur d'Italie Luca Anastasio
anata ainsi que son garde du corps et un
chauffeur avait été tué par balle dans
une pris dans une embuscade aux abords
du parc national des viranga au nord de
la ville de Goma dans le Nord qui vous
après une suspension en début de mois le
tribunal s'est déclaré compétent écoutez
le récit de notre correspondante Aurélie
bazarra kibangula à la barre Issa l'un
des cinq prévenus a répondu calmement
aux questions du tribunal installées
sous une grande tente dans l'enceinte de
la prison militaire de Dolo pour le
ministère public il s'agissait de
vérifier la thèse du kidnapping qui a
mal tourné les ravisseurs comptaient
prendre en otage le diplomate italien et
exigé une rançon l'ambassadeur a
finalement été tué par balle avec son
garde du corps et le chauffeur des
Nations Unies le 22 février 2021 devant
le tribunal le magistrat a eu des
extraits des auditions dit ça faites par
les enquêteurs de la police judiciaire
de Goma ces extraits à crédites la thèse
du kidnapping et la participation dit ça
au meurtre du diplomate italien mais à
la barre le prévenu à répéter pendant
trois heures que ces aveux ont été faits
sous la torture il nie tous les faits
qui lui sont reprochés il explique avoir
appris le meurtre du diplomate italien
en écoutant la radio pour les avocats de
la défense c'est un procès monté de
pièce ils nous ont dit qu'il n'y a
didouilles ni arme ni relevé
téléphonique dans le dossier les quatre
autres prévenus présents dans le box des
accusés livreront leur version des faits
la semaine prochaine tous sont accusés
de meurtre association de malfaiteurs et
des tensions d'armes et de munitions de
guerre on part après Toria en Afrique du
Sud ou se poursuivent et pour parler de
paix entre le gouvernement éthiopien et
les rebelles du Tigré pour trouver une
solution pacifique et durable à la
guerre qui ravage le nord du pays depuis
deux ans au même moment Amnesty
International révèle que le conflit a
été jalonné des actions sur les civils
des crimes contre l'humanité commis par
toutes les parties en toute impunité les
explications de Laurent Berthet
il n'y a pas de partie innocente au
conflit éthiopien selon Amnesty
International tous les acteurs de la
guerre du tigree se sont rendus
coupables de violation des droits de
l'homme et même dans certains cas de
crimes de guerre et de crimes contre
l'humanité
les forces de défense nationale
éthiopiennes les Forces erytrées
Spéciales Amara la milice amarafano
toutes ces parties ont commis de graves
violations des droits de l'homme
notamment des viols et des violences
sexuelles
l'ONG demande une enquête approfondie et
indépendante afin d'établir les
responsabilités et de traduire les
coupables en justice conformément aux
droits international un appel qui
intervient alors que les dirigeants
éthiopiens et tigrésens se réunissent
pour un deuxième jour de pourparler de
paix à Pretoria
les négociations qui ont débuté mardi
sous l'égide de l'Union africaine sont
suivis de très près par les Nations
Unies l'organisation internationale
appelle depuis des semaines à un cessé
le feu immédiat au tigree elle a une
nouvelle fois exhorté les deux parties à
saisir cette ultime chance pour trouver
une solution diplomatique au conflits
c'est la seule façon d'avancer si les
parties ne s'engagent pas vraiment dans
une solution négociée nous serons dans
cette situation pour toujours
depuis la reprise des combats fin août
l'armée éthiopienne enregistre des
avancées majeures sur le terrain mais
les dirigeants du TPLF affirmaient lundi
encore posséder une capacité militaire
suffisante pour vaincre leurs ennemis
direction le quartier populaire d'Abobo
dans la capitale économique ivoirienne
c'est là que vit Messenger Cissé depuis
10 ans cette mère de famille s'occupe
des enfants des rues qu'on appelle la
vague des microbes des jeunes tombés
dans l'extrême délinquance et qui
terrorise la population une fois la nuit
tombée loin de les stigmatiser celle qui
est surnommée maman microbes les traite
avec considération et affection comme si
c'était ses propres enfants Sophie
Lamotte et sages amandjo l'ont rencontré
c'est la maman de tous les enfants de la
rue 10 ans que Messenger Cissé s'occupe
de ces mineurs souvent orphelin et livré
à eux-mêmes les plus violents sont
surnommés les microbes mais Messenger
Cissé rappelle que ce sont des enfants
qu'il faut protéger pour appeler les
enfants microbes vraiment moi ça me
plaît pas à cause de ça je fais au
combat pour qu'on va me laisser nos
microbes c'est le être humain les
enfants aussi voilà c'est la l'enfant là
il a quitté à l'école
5e 4e il est au dehors si on l'a aidé
qui continue à l'école il peut devenir
gouverneur demain il peut gouverner Côte
d'Ivoire demain
dans son modeste salon Messenger héberge
une quinzaine d'enfants pour les nourrir
elle ne peut que compter sur le salaire
de son mari commerçant elle aimerait
avoir les moyens et le soutien des
autorités pour en faire encore plus j'ai
beaucoup des enfants j'ai envie de
travailler mais le point me manque j'ai
besoin d'un bail un maison conçue voilà
pour que je vais encadrer les enfants là
bien c'est ça qui me manque actuellement
dans les rues d'Abobo tout le monde la
connaît car c'est dans ce quartier du
nord de la capitale économique qu'il y a
le plus de délinquance leur nombre a
explosé depuis la crise politique de
2011 pour lutter contre la précarité du
quartier Messenger aide les plus grands
à s'insérer dans la vie professionnelle
c'est le cas de ces jeunes couturiers
qui travaillent aujourd'hui dans cet
atelier
une trentaine d'ex enfants de la rue
sont devenus couturier coiffeur ou
employés de maison pour elle c'est en
apportant un cadre stable à ses enfants
de la rue que la Côte d'Ivoire
éradiquera le phénomène de la
délinquance juvénile
et un mot pour vous dire que l'écrivaine
mauricienne Natacha à Pana a reçu pour
l'ensemble de son œuvre le prix de la
langue française elle sera honorée à la
Foire du livre de Brive du 4 6 novembre
prochain et elle a fait sensation avec
un style percutant notamment avec Tropic
de la violence qui est émergé de son
séjour à Mayotte un roman multi primé
notamment par le prix féminin des
lycéens c'était en 2016
c'est ainsi qu'on referme cette édition
de journal Afrique merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivi en particulier ceux de
Paris au Luxembourg en passant par
Athènes restez avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur France 24
[Musique]